the fact that after the first
investigation a number of other forces
have come forward doesn't surprise me
these investigations always seem to
snowball
my guess is they'd probably be others in
due course in terms of the actual
allegations for the four years that I
worked for him which was 88 to 92 you as
his private secretary
we were overseeing every aspect of what
he was doing for every minute of every
day and when I found out or heard these
allegations yesterday I was absolutely
shocked because there was no way in that
four-year period that he ever slipped
away for either being in I suppose me
observing what he was doing or Special
Branch who were looking after him at the
time observing what he was doing or when
he was at his home in Wiltshire the
local police force in Wiltshire
observing what he was doing and a number
of it is in the public domain anyway
because records of who went in and out
of his house were always kept and they
are public records now did you ever hear
any rumors about him heard rumors about
whether he was gay which back in the
1980s perhaps was a frequent allegation
that could be dropped I think these days
those sorts of allegations would just be
dismissed who cares if someone's gay
these days in reality but in those days
25 years ago that was something that for
someone who wasn't married could be an
allegation put forward he never I never
had any inkling he was gay if I'm honest
I thought he was asexual I suppose if
there was one time ever in those four
years we had a conversation about
relationships
it was ironically I just told him I was
thinking of getting engaged to my to my
now wife and he then went on to say that
actually he'd had two if you like quite
close relationships with women that he
did wonder whether they were ever gone
the full distance but never did but
never was our discussion about any
relationship with men and certainly the
idea of him being a pedophile is beyond
my wildest dream I you know the
allegations are out there now they have
to be investigated I hope they're
investigated swiftly but then I'm
absolutely sure that certainly through
that period of saw the 80s nearly 90s
there will be no evidence whatsoever and
this could hopefully we'll all be put to
rest
you referred to some of the security
that was around him as a former prime
minister when you work for him give us a
bit more details on that
to what extent were a special branch
around him at all times well so when I
was with him when I first started
working for him he had Special Branch
24 hours a day seven days a week home
and abroad during that period when he
went overseas Special Branch was taken
away from him but domestically in the UK
he would always have special bonds with
him or you know so he goes to a
restaurant the next table is a Special
Branch officer I should say an armed
Special Branch officer sorry that's just
fallen out but if if he was um sorry
bear with me thank you sir about that if
he'd also have his driver with him as
well so two people at all times with him
except when he went into his house where
again I'd say the local Wiltshire
Constabulary would then man the gates
and you know sign people in and out of
his house but it was something as a
public figure as a former prime minister
you get to live with it's just part of
the routine but it does mean there is
always someone who has a record of where
he was and just to say how far that
extended as a politician on a Monday
morning if I hadn't seen him over the
weekend
Monday morning my first conversation
will be with a special branch say was
there anything that happened away from
what was in the diary he might decide to
have gone to the local pub in which case
no doubt I'd be expected to draft a
letter to the public or the landlord
saying what a great meal it was lovely
beer why don't you you know get some of
X different sort of whiskey next time so
we would already be catching up to make
sure we documented everything that was
going on even if it was outside what was
in the formal diary there will be
records of all of this I'm sure the
police will be going through all these
details and I am certain in the period
when I knew Teddy very well that there
will be no grounds for any of these
allegations to be anything other than
dismissed as soon as possible